All right, let's build a killer keyword list. Now, what does that mean? Why are we doing
this so early? I'm going to go over all of those things, but first of all, I want to
cover why we are taking the time at this stage of the game. All we've done at this point
is pick the niche, and if you haven't picked the niche, you pick a niche, and if you don't
know what to pick, pick concrete, okay, just to recap from our last lesson. But we've picked
the niche, you're like, why are we already doing the keyword list? Okay, so there's many
reasons to this, and I'm going to go over a couple of them, but guys, it's very, very,
very crucial that you stop what you're doing and you do this step. Don't just watch this
module, or sorry, don't just watch this lesson, watch this lesson and do what I'm asking,
okay? All right, so why does this matter? Why does it matter to have our keyword list
dialed in? And what I mean by that is these are the keywords that we're going to be targeting
for our SEO, for our ads, for everything within that niche. So let's just assume that we're
doing concrete, because I've said if you don't know what to do, you're going to do concrete.
So the number one thing, the first thing that I think you need to understand is that in
order for us to run ads, which is going to be part of this game, now for some of you
that already have sites that are producing leads, this process works just the same and
you're going to use your leads that are already coming in organically, that's fine. But for
everybody else that wants to pre-sell and is just starting, and this niche is starting
from scratch, you are going to need to run ads, okay? That's how we're going to speed
this deal up. And as such, we're going to have to set up keyword themes, or we're going
to have to pick our keyword inside of our ads. So what keywords do we pick? Well, if
we do the keyword list correctly from the beginning, that becomes very simple, okay?
Also, what kind of ad copy do we want to include? Well, we're going to want to include some
keywords into our ad copy. So, you know, it's very, very crucial. The second thing, so number
one is we're going to need these keywords for the ads. Number two, remember that the
long-term game here, unless you're somebody who's just going to come in and, you know,
sell, and by the way, you could do this, but if you're somebody that's going to come in
and sell a deal for a thousand bucks a month, run $500 in ads and just take the difference
and never build out a website, that's totally fine. But I completely, completely, completely
recommend that once you do that and you get the deal, you then take the money from the
deal and build out the actual website. And when you build out the actual website, you're
going to need to know what kind of content to write. And you're going to want to look
at your keywords for that. And you're going to want to know what H1 tags, and we're going
to, by the way, if you have questions on this, we're going to get into that. It's fine. But
if you want to know what type of, you know, heading to use, you want to know what to put
as your page title and your meta description and what to name your images, it all ties
back to the keyword list. Okay. So it's super, super, super crucial that you spend the time
to do this correctly. Also, guys, one thing that I made a huge mistake, and you've heard
me talk about having to get rid of 125 sites. One of the things I made a huge mistake with
is when I was doing my due diligence, my market research, whatever you want to call it, I
used to just use one keyword. So if I was doing concrete, I would go type in concrete
Orlando Florida, and I would look at the metrics and I would base it on one keyword. Okay.
And guys, if you base a decision on one keyword, you are rolling the dice, man. It's like going
and buying a piece of real estate and literally basing it off of one thing, basing it off
what the rents are. That's like, okay, well, the rents are 2000 bucks a month. Great.
That's not looking at how much capital expenditure you're going to need into the roof. It's not
looking at HOA fees. It's not looking at, you know, is that a desirable area? Is the
area growing? It's like looking at one factor of a real estate deal and putting money down.
That's the same as using one keyword to analyze a deal. Okay. So I did this incorrectly and
I didn't know what I was doing. So we're going to take this keyword list and we are going
to use at least five of the keywords that we, that we derive from this keyword list
to analyze the deal. So you need to make sure this is done correctly. Okay. I'm telling
you, this is so, so important. I've done this the wrong way and it is a nightmare.
All right, guys, the cool part about this too is you only have to do this once per niche.
So if you're going to do concrete, you do this correctly. You do it once. Now, if you
build five, 10, 15 more concrete sites, you don't have to keep doing it over and over
you just need to build a keyword list once. Okay. And what I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you guys an example of what happens when you don't do this correctly. You don't
look at the keyword research. You don't analyze the competition correctly because you only
look at one keyword. And I'm going to show you what happens. All right, guys. So I went
into this niche called foundation repair and I will tell you right now, this is one of
those niches that is very high ticket. I thought it was going to be a home run. It ended up
being, oh my gosh, I don't even want to get into, I spent a lot of money thinking I was
going to just crush it in this niche. But that's neither here nor there. What I wanted
to show you is this site has been live for, I kid you not, multiple years. We've been
running SEO on this site and it hasn't been done perfectly. But typically based on the
way that I now teach it and the way that I now pick cities and niches, even without doing
much, I would be ranking or I would at least be close to ranking. And I'm showing you right
now at the time of recording, this site has been live for at least three years. At least
three years. And for the main term, I am literally sitting on page five. I am literally sitting
on page five. In fact, this is a website that's on my list. I need to just cut this website.
This is not going anywhere. It's not doing anything. So if nothing else, guys, this should
be a great example of why you have got to make sure to do this keyword list correctly
so that you don't make these mistakes. All right. So guys, how do we actually build the
keyword list? So what I would recommend is I like to either get a piece of paper, pull
up a document, whatever. You can use a Google doc. It doesn't matter. You can use a note,
a sticky note. It does not matter. But the first thing that we're going to do is we're
going to use a tool. And it doesn't matter what tool you use. I just want you to use
the same tool every time you do this. So whatever you decide to choose, whatever you decide
to go with, use that again and again and again. Don't be bouncing here and there and
everywhere and using different tools because we want to keep this consistent. So what we're
going to do is we're first going to choose a tool. Okay. And for this example, I'm going
to use SEMrush. Now with this product, there is a 14 or seven day trial. I don't know.
It is an expensive product. It's just something that I'm familiar with. And the person that
I learned from the beginning was using it. So it's something I'm familiar with and I'm
going to be able to teach this really quickly using SEMrush. Now there's other examples
or other options you can use. Ahrefs, Mangools, Google Keyword Planner is a great free tool
that I would definitely recommend using if you don't want to spend money. For the sake
of this example, I'm going to use SEMrush. Okay. So what we're going to do is we're going
to choose a tool and then we are going to go and we're going to find out within the
niche that you selected, we're going to find the 10 to 15 main most highly searched terms.
So for example, I'm going to show you and demonstrate here in a second with concrete.
Within concrete, there's a lot of things that people could search. They could search cheap
concrete. They could search how much does concrete cost. They could search concrete
contractors. They could search concrete patio. Which of those terms are the most highly searched
nationwide or in your country? If you're outside of the US, totally fine. Which of these terms
are searched most in your country? That's what we're going to do first. Okay. So I'm
going to show you an example right now. All right guys. So again, like I said, I'm going
to use SEMrush for this. I think it's SEM. It might be SEM. I don't know, but it's going
to be really, really simple. So if you're doing concrete and we're going to use this
example because I am assuming a lot of people are going to use, are going to go into concrete.
So you're going to start off with your tool, whether it's keyword plan or whatever. You're
going to just type in the main term, which is concrete. If you're using, if you're doing
spray foam installation, type in spray foam installation. If you're doing artificial grass,
type in whatever comes to mind. Artificial grass, fake grass, turf. Just type in something.
And what we're going to start doing is we're going to look at it. Okay, concrete. And we're
not going to add the city. We're not going to add any city because we haven't even got
to that point yet. But we're just going to type in the main term. So concrete. And I'm
going to look at this and go, okay, that's interesting. There's 110,000 searches. And
you could see this as keyword difficulty. Don't pay attention to this. It's not, it
doesn't matter right now. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to take that term. I'm
going to write it down. And then what I'm going to do is I'm going to start like looking
in these sections here for what would I would consider, uh, uh, they, they call them, um,
related. Sorry. I should just look at this related keywords. Okay. So concrete calculator,
you got to use your intuition as well because like concrete calculator, that's more of like
somebody that's looking to do their own project. So no concrete cowboy. No. So concrete contractors
near me. Okay. 40,000, 40.5 K. That's a good one. I'm going to write that one down. Okay.
And this is what we're going to do. And we're going to click on these and there's going
to be other ones that come up. Um, you know, and then we're also, okay, here's a good,
here's a good one. Concrete patio contractors. So we're going to kind of use our intuition.
So we're going to go through and first thing we're going to do is compile a list of the,
the main term and related terms. Okay. Another idea I want to share with you guys when you're
coming up with this, cause we need to go and get 10 to 15 terms is what you could do is
you could go to a really competitive city. So let's just use like, um, uh, let's use
Atlanta. So let's do concrete Atlanta, Georgia. Okay. And you can look at the top ranking
companies. All right. So for example, this is the top ranking company for this term,
Sudlow concrete. And you're going to use their site to generate ideas. So for example, concrete
contractors. Okay. That's interesting. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to type
in concrete contractors. I'm going to remove the near me and Oh, what do you know? 27.1
thousand. Boom. I'm writing that down. And then based on that, you can start looking
at the related keywords again. Right? Okay. We already wrote that one down. Now concrete
contractors. We're going to write that one down. Concrete contractor. That might be interesting
to write down. Right. And we're going to go back to their site. We're going to check
it out. Okay. Uh, we could look at top rated concrete contracts. I have done this niche
enough to know that's not, but that's something you could look at if you were just going into
the niche things you want to look at on the page is you want to look at, you know, their
service pages. There's, those are going to be the most highly searched terms. So for
example, um, uh, driveway repair could be interesting. I also know like just using my
intuition driveway repair, you know, it's probably going to be more high ticket, uh,
concrete patio. Let's just use that for an example. So I'll, I'll do one more example
and I'm just going to give you my list here. Concrete patio. Okay. Boom. 12.1 thousand.
So guys, and then look, stamped concrete patio. What I want you to first do is I want you
to make a list of 10 to 15 terms that are the most highly searched term in the niche
that you selected. Okay. All right, guys, I went ahead and just grabbed one of my keyword
lists. Uh, I mean, we go into this niche, we're in this niche all over the country.
So I know what keywords are good. Don't mind the highlighted stuff. I'll explain that in
a moment. So this is my compiled list. I did 18 terms. Um, it's not, you know, it's, it's
not a hundred percent complete, but I I've done this enough to know these terms are really,
really good. So I got concrete contractor, concrete company, concrete driveway, and I
just have them listed here. Okay. So what you want to do is you want to have your list.
And by the way, I have this in base camp. Don't recommend this. Um, I just, I'm telling
you that so you don't go and think you need to get base camp. There's something we use
and it's just already in here, but it's not worth the money. Um, I'm telling you that
in fact, we got a free trial of this. And so that's why I'm still using it. Okay. So
what you're going to do is you're going to take your, your, let's call it 10 to 15 keywords.
And then what you're going to do from there is you're going to take, and you're going
to use your intuition and you're going to select five to 10. I prefer like seven being
the sweet spot. You're going to select five to 10 of these keywords closer to five than
10. In fact, I'm just going to tell you, do five top set. Okay. Five to seven of these
keywords. And I'm going to have you use your intuition and say, okay, would that keyword
be something I want to focus on because of, uh, it's high ticket. It's, you know, it's
not someone that's looking around like, for example, uh, conk, cheap concrete near me.
I don't want those leads. That's some cheap ass. I don't want that. Okay. So anyway, I
went ahead and these highlighted ones are the ones that I determined as, you know, they're
really interesting keywords to me. And so what we're going to do is pick those five
to seven and these are going to be what we call core keywords. Okay. So just to recap,
we're going to go in, we're going to pick, or we're going to go find the terms that are
most searched across the nation. Okay. Concrete concrete contractor, concrete company, concrete
driveway, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. From that list of 10 to 15 to 20, we're going
to select five to seven of those keywords. And here's the interesting thing. It's not
always based on the search volume. Cause if you look at the actual total volume, notice
how concrete repair has more volume than a lot of these terms are very similar volume
to some of these terms, yet it didn't make the cut, right? Because I know people looking
for concrete repair. Those are really small jobs. Okay. So you're going to pick those
top terms. Okay. And I didn't include that because I just decorative concrete kind of
goes with polished concrete, but it's, it's didn't, I didn't, I didn't include it. Okay.
And you're going to come up with what are called your core keyword list. Okay. That's
going to be five to seven keywords. Now what you're going to do from here is very simple,
but we're going to build what are called expanded core keyword list for each of these terms.
Okay. So I'm going to tell you the terms that I selected. I selected concrete contractor.
I put, I don't know even know why this, this, in fact, I need to edit that. That shouldn't
even be in there. Concrete specialist should not be in there. In fact, for the sake of
this, let me go ahead and just delete this. Um, that, that was not done by me. Um, yeah,
I don't actually know why that's in there. Okay. There's no volume. It's not a great
term. So just forget you ever saw a concrete specialist. Don't add it. Stupid term. Not
that much volume, not that great of a term. Okay. But here are the core keywords that
I chose. Okay. To build my expanded lists on. And this is all going to make sense. So
just stay with me. Okay. Concrete contractor, concrete company, stamp concrete, concrete
staining, concrete driveway, concrete patio, polished concrete. Okay. I actually did like
eight or nine of these. Um, but I recommend doing seven. I don't, I actually do not use,
um, I can tell you this because we just did a site recently. I don't use these, uh, decorative
concrete terms. They were just built because we, in the beginning we thought we were going
to do that. So something important to note about concrete, there is decorative side and
then there's the flat work side. And most of these people, they want flat work stuff.
So I would, I would err on that side. But what I'm going to show you is you're going
to pick your five to seven terms. If you want to do a couple more, that's totally fine.
It's just going to take you a little bit longer. Guys. So what we're going to do is we're going
to take those five to seven keywords, your core keywords, and we're going to build an
expanded keyword list. Okay. And so what we're going to do is very, very simple. You're going
to take your first term. Okay. So you're going to go over and take your first term
concrete contractor. Okay. You're going to come over here and you're going to type it
into Google. Okay. And then what you're going to do is you're going to scroll the bottom
and you're going to see these related searches and it's going to give you ideas. These are
things people are searching and I want you to use your intuition. Should this be added
to the list or not? So concrete contractor near St. George, Utah. I'm not going to do
that one because I don't even know if I'm going into St. George yet. We're just picking
the niche at this point. So no near Las Vegas. No concrete pouring near me. Maybe. Okay.
Maybe you would add that. Maybe not concrete contractor salary. No, that's going to pull
people looking for jobs. Okay. Residential concrete contract. That's a really good one.
I would add that to my list. Okay. And what you're going to do is you're going to take
that keyword and you're going to go over here and you're going to add it to your list. Okay.
And you guys don't overthink this. Don't overthink this. Okay. Con concrete contractor jobs. No.
Okay. Not doing that one. Concrete calculator. Probably not doing that one. That's probably
somebody looking to do a project themselves. Residential concrete contractors near me.
Yeah, we might, but it's getting a little long tail. So I don't know. Okay. So that's
what you're going to do is you're going to do that with all of your terms and you're
going to start building these individual lists. Another thing that you can do is you can go
and use the alphabet. So you go to concrete contractor. In fact, it typically, let me
go ahead and let go like this and open a new incognito window and do in concrete contractor
actually, let's go to Google first. Okay. We're going to go concrete contractor. Okay.
And then we're going to start with the letter A. Okay. Type in A. Whoops. And you're going
to see, why is it caps? There we go. And you're going to look and see if there's anything
with A. Association? No. Atlanta? No. Aberdeen? No. No. It's a lot of, a lot of city stuff.
So no. Okay. Okay. B. No. A lot of cities. Business plan. Nope. C. Okay. Concrete contractor
contract. No. Cost. Concrete contractor cost. That's an interesting one. I'd add that to
my list. Concrete contractor companies near me. Add that to the list. Okay. I'm still
going to avoid the calculator. We're going to go D. No. No. E. Estimate. I'd probably
add that. Okay. F. Nothing. G. Lot of cities with this term. And you're going to do this
H. Okay. You're just going to keep doing this with every one of your course. You're going
to do this five times all the way through the alphabet. And for whatever reason with
concrete contractor, you're going to kind of get a lot of cities, but let's try and
change the term. Let's do concrete patio and let's go A. Okay. Now you can see there's
a lot less cities. So A. Alternatives. Probably not. Around window well. No. Against house.
Probably around pool. I'll probably add that one. Depending on where you're at. Right?
If you're in somewhere that doesn't have pools, like where I grew up, don't do that. Okay.
It's not going to be a good one. Concrete patio and fire pit. Maybe. Okay. B. Concrete
patio blocks. And you're just going to go through and you're going to just use your
intuition. You're going to grab the ones that make sense. Concrete patio backyard. What
you would search for as a consumer, as a customer that would be interesting? C. Cost. I think
we talked about that one. Yes. Concrete patio contractors near me. Yes. Concrete patio contractors.
Yes. Concrete patio cleaner. No. Concrete patio square foot. Maybe. But probably not.
Concrete patio coatings. Yes. Go to D. And you guys, you're just going to go through.
So to recap, you're going to go through all of your five core keywords. You're going to
type it in. You're going to, you know, for patio, you're going to first go to the bottom.
You're going to look at related. You're going to grab the related block. Heck no, Google.
You're going to look at the related. You're going to add those to the list. And then you're
going to do the alphabet game. You're going to go A through whatever with the term. So
concrete patio space. Okay. Concrete patio space in every letter of the alphabet. And
look at the auto fill suggestions. And what you're going to do is you're going to build
out these expanded keyword lists. And guys, if you get the keyword, the core keywords
dialed in and you then expand the keyword list, you're going to be off to a great start.
You're going to be able to use this keyword list over and over and over. So guys, to recap,
what you're going to do is you are going to go and pick a tool. Okay. If you don't want
to spend money, do Google keyword, Google keyword planner. I think that's what it's
called. Okay. Pick a tool and stick with that tool. Then you're going to go and you're going
to type in the main term. And from there, you're going to start building a list of 10
to 15 to 20 core keywords. Things that people, they're the most highly searched thing based
on what this tool tells you. Okay. From that list, you are then going to pick five to seven
core keywords. From those core keywords, you are going to build an expanded list on each
of those keywords. And you're going to do it by first typing it into Google and looking
at the very bottom at the related keywords and then going to Google and typing in the
keyword, pushing space and then the letter A and then looking at those automatic fills.
Hey, do any of these make sense? You're going to do that for every single letter of the
alphabet for all five to seven keywords. I know it sounds like a lot. I know that, but
guys, if you do this once and you do it correctly for concrete, you're never going to have to
do this. If you do 15 concrete sites, a hundred concrete sites, you will never have to do
this again. So it's worth doing and doing correctly. And I want to say this last thing.
Do not overthink this. Do not overthink this. Remember our goal is to go into cities and
niches with low competition. So even if we do this 75% correctly, we're going to win.
But I'm telling you, if you do this correctly and you take the time, it is going to help
you immensely. And you're going to be able to use this keyword for your ads. You're going
to be able to use this keyword list for your ad copy. You're going to be able to use it
for your SEO, for your content. It is worth doing and doing correctly. And you only got
to do it once.